[Music]
it's the moment we've been waiting for
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
say i do in a stunning wedding ceremony
in portofino italy in front of family
and friends it's a beautiful thing
a story tells et that courtney and
travis quote couldn't be happier adding
quote the whole weekend has been amazing
and their italy wedding is everything
they ever wanted their friends and
family are all so thrilled for them and
can see how in love they are
the event comes after the couple legally
tied the nod in a california courthouse
last week during the italian ceremony
courtney was smiling from ear to ear as
she was escorted down the aisle by her
mother kris jenner
travis and courtney exchanged vows on a
red carpeted altar with their children
by their side
as a symbol of their unity the boy stood
behind courtney and the girl stood
behind travis
speaking of the girls travis's daughter
alabama shared this selfie with the
bride on instagram
as well as this video of courtney and
travis holding hands at the altar
when it comes to courtney's dress for
their special day she wore a short white
corseted dress with a lace overlay by
dolce gabbana with her hair up she
paired the dress with a stunning
cathedral veil that is embroidered with
a large image of the virgin mary and the
words family loyalty respect
when it comes to the groom travis donned
a perfectly tailored dark gray tuxedo
and just like his missus it was also by
dolce gabbana take a closer look at both
of their ensembles with this shot of the
couple headed to their reception where
you can see that courtney ditched the
long veil and kept it fun with her white
lace dress and white lace pumps we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah
courtney's sisters kim khloe kendall and
kylie were all in italy for the weekend
celebrations
[Music]
kylie gave an inside look into the
reception on her insta story showing
someone making fresh cannolis and pasta
[Music]
before courtney and travis said i do
courtney was seen in a mini dress also
embroidered with the face of virgin mary
and a black and blue lace veil as she
held hands with travis barker and her
son rain
courtney gave a closer look at the dress
on instagram captioning these two pics
quote here comes the dot dot dot
and then in the same outfit courtney is
seen cuddling up next to travis on a
boat
it's always amazing
courtney and travis got engaged in
october of 2021 10 months after the long
time friends and neighbors started
dating
congrats to the happy couple
[Music]